[Music]
these hands who i once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out
exactly who i am
[Music]
i want to choose my own path
live in the moment
[Music]
my superheroing days are over
[Music]
[Music]
remember what i told you
[Music]
you ever feel lost
just look into the eyes of the people
that you love
[Music]
not me
what just listening
[Music]
let's talk business
this guy comes to town every tuesday are
you free tuesday
yeah i'm free tuesday
you can't stop what you can't see this
guy came from the outside it was a pro
it was fast
in the art of the kill
leon was the master somebody's coming up
somebody's serious he never missed a hit
[Music]
he never got caught you're a
destructible bullet slide after you
played with him
and above all else
he never had a reason to care
until now
i like these scarring little moments
before the storm
my family was shot down by dea officers
three kids here one of them is missing
find her
please open the door
please
from the director of la femme nikita
don't help me i'll die tonight i can
feel it
an innocent girl
with no one else to turn to what exactly
do you do for a living cleaner you mean
you're a hit man
cool
a perfect assassin i need you to help me
leon
i want to get those dirt bags who kills
my brother
with someone to finally believe in
change
[Music]
remember that leon
i will they're about to come face to
face with the cop who's crossed the line
bring me everyone
you mean everyone everyone
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i will not let this republic be split in
two my negotiations will not fail if
they do there aren't enough jedi to
protect the republic we're keepers of
the peace not soldiers
[Music]
you know i don't like it when you do
that sorry master i forgot you don't
like flying
well you've lost it if you'll excuse me
i hate it when he does that anakin don't
do anything without first consulting
either myself or the council you don't
need guidance anakin i see you becoming
the greatest of all jedi
the boy has exceptional skills his
abilities have made him arrogant excuse
me
i'm in charge of security here milady
[Music]
they are using a bounty hunter named
jango fett to create a clone army wait
we must stop them before they're ready
your clones are very impressive they'll
do their job well
blast that's why i hate
flying this is a crisis
the senate must vote the chancellor
emergency powers as my first act i will
create a grand army of the republic
to counter the increasing threats of the
separatists it has been a full-scale war
since the formation of the republic
you must join me obi-wan and together we
will destroy the sith
the dark side clouds everything in grave
danger you are
[Music]
[Music]
the gun this clone war has
[Music]
drink a baby
[Music]
your down behind
cause it's all going off without you
excuse me
you're wrong
[Music]
[Music]
for
[Music]
i wish i wasn't afraid all the time but
i am
people should not be afraid of their
governments
governments should be afraid of their
people
those caught in violation of curfew will
be prosecuted without leniency or
exception it's past curfew you know
oh not tonight
who are you
gentlemen i want this terrorist foul
and i want him to understand what terror
really means
we're working on several leaves
her parents were detained when she was
12.
it was like those black bags erased them
from the face of the
you have one chance
you must tell us the whereabouts of
codename v
if our own government was responsible
for the deaths of a hundred thousand
people you really want to know
those who are responsible will be held
accountable
the time has come for you to live
without fear
i'm ready
this country stands on the edge of
oblivion i want everyone to remember why
they need
killing
[Music]
my turn
i suddenly had this feeling
that everything was connected
we're all part of it
are we ready for it
the only verdict
is vengeance
i had the craziest dream last night
about a girl who was turned into a swan
but her prince falls for the wrong girl
when
she kills herself
[Music]
he promised to feature me more this
season well he should you've been there
long enough
and you're the most dedicated dancer in
the company
[Music]
our new swan queen the exquisite
ninasaurs
i'm lily you're gonna be amazing i'll
watch the way she moves essential she's
not faking it
seduces attack it attack it come on
where'd you get these it's nothing
you sweet girl
feel my touch respond to it
it's so hot for teacher i don't want to
talk about that we really need to relax
it's the role isn't it it's all this
pressure i knew it'd be too much i knew
it oh what's she doing here he made me
your alternate
the only person standing in your way is
you
[Music]
how do you know where i live i have my
ways
she's after me
nobody's after you
please believe me
what happened to my sweet girl
she's gone
[Music]
ah
[Music]
in a faraway land there lived two
brothers
one brave and bold the other
not so much
courtney will you make funny faces to
entertain me
[Laughter]
no never triangle face i hate trying
triangle face it scares me
your brother is about to embark on a
quest the evil wizard lazar has taken my
love
you must journey with your brother to
rescue his bride
can i sleep on it
i don't think you'll need that armor you
make quests the way you like i will
quest the way i like here i come
oh this quest sucks i shouldn't even be
here i will probably die on this quest
courtney definitely will if we work
together we can destroy lazar once and
for all with our huge muscles we shall
protect you oh really oh really
[Music]
that didn't really go as planned
what right here to spy on a bathing
woman for simply keeping an eye on her
oh god she's looking at us remain
perfectly still
[Music]
why would anyone want to be with you i'm
not sure really oh yeah perhaps because
i'm rich i live in a castle and i can do
magic
you've got to suck out the venom i don't
want a sucker you suck it i can't reach
you with my mouth courtney suck the
venom i've never sucked it
whenever you maidens are ready
[Music]
finally alone
thaddeus yes i've not been able to stop
thinking of you what a coincidence i was
just about to finish thinking of you
your highness we come to see council
come come give me kisses kiss him hell
no father quest
hello
nice to meet you
[Music]
it's not easy to do what you did
you made my man look like a bunch of
minimum wage mall cops
that's hurtful
would you like to tell me where you
received your training
afghanistan
chechnya
who are you
[Music]
i have sacrificed much
to achieve peace
fall
through your arrogance and stupidity you
have opened these peaceful realms and
innocent lives
to the horror
and devastation of war
you are a vain greedy cruel boy
and you are an old man and a fool you're
unworthy
father
i now take from you
your power
i cast you out
please open your eyes
oh no this is a physical where he comes
from
your ancestors called it magic
and you call it science i come from a
place where they're one in the same
his fate is in his own hands now
i will end this
people like to believe in fairy tales
you ready
of course
[Music]
and you
i believe that the characters we read
about on the page end up being more real
than the men who stand beside us
[Music]
[Music]
i am saying jack
jack can you hear me
jack let me check
[Music]
people need their history
they need to know that real men actually
lived here
[Music]
i have grown accustomed to a great
divide between what people believe and
what i know to be real and how would you
like him remembered there should be more
horses more soldiers why are you doing
this mr kennedy there's more crying more
cameras this is making us look like
barbarians what's wrong with you you
don't have to do this i will march with
jack breathe
alone if necessary
i'm not the first lady anymore
i lost jack somewhere
what was real
what was performance
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm guessing you won't allow me to write
any of that
no
because i never said that
lucy
time to wrap it up
just a few more minutes
[Music]
i saw my house from space
not literally but my life
[Music]
yep there it is uh excuse me major
goldman has a theory that he can tell
who's walked in space just by looking at
it is more than a theory
[Music]
you keep your eye on this one so i'll
show you how it's done i'm so proud of
you
love you to the moon and back you know
michael collins of course apollo 11 and
i flew the command module for neil and
buzz so you know that after he dropped
them he circled the moon
for hours
inside the module he wrote i am now
truly alone and absolutely alone from
any known life i am
i need to get back up there
not getting any younger so you're just
gonna have to work harder
look at you straight arrow you've never
done anything wrong in your life i've
done plenty of things wrong really
hit me
[Music]
dr plimpton said you skipped your last
three sessions i'm giving everything to
this program to the mission it kills me
to say it but our girl's been pretty
inconsistent recently cola aboard
negative i can finish oh she's tough
cookie get the laptop
not everyone can handle the ride
i'm pulling you out of the running for a
ride no if i were a man you would excuse
me
i know what you're doing but you're
gonna lose
because i'm a winner
this is not a drill cadet grab your
stuff what are you doing
with her i'm officially beginning to
worry
you're acting so strange
[Music]
i'm good
all sisters got one
what's a mic up there
only place where anything makes sense
i hear that
[Music]
you